I'm Chris Colbert welcome to the program
on a day that provides a rude awakening
for thousands of meta employees as the
Facebook owner is beginning major
layoffs according to the Wall Street
Journal CEO Mark Zuckerberg acknowledged
the company's recent missed steps and
says that his over optimism about growth
had led to overstaffing but layoffs of
meta which currently employs 87 000
people are just some among many tech
jobs currently cut in Silicon Valley
Twitter just fired over half of its
people after Elon Musk took over the
site although the company is apparently
trying to get some of them back over at
Microsoft 1000 of over 200 000 employees
are being laid off and the world's
largest retailer online retailer Amazon
has announced a hiring freeze for the
coming months let's take a closer look
at the matter with Alicia Garcia Herrero
she is the chief Economist for Asia
Pacific at naxis investment managers
welcome to the program Alicia well is it
just the worsening economy economic
climate and Tech firms taking in Less ad
Revenue that is to blame here
so it is not only the US it's Europe and
China decelerating at the same time and
for different reasons but these all
affects of course tech companies because
their motto is growth yeah and pentap
demand they have done wonderfully after
covet because until we go with it
because that's where we're all booked in
a way but now the revenue is in this the
house of Revenue is trunking and that's
why they are suffering but beyond that
there is also a sense of fatigue
with households with consumers for what
probably has become too much of a good
thing and that's more structural so you
know I think there is two things to note
the cyclical which may be solved if the
economy bounces back when interest rates
will come down again and it's going to
take a while but the structural part I
think they should be worried about their
model because you know climate change
all of these new ways to think that
people thinking about you know other
things that is not just Tech it's
something that is going to harm them
yeah so the tech sector is changing uh
as a whole has its challenges certainly
I want to look at meta here uh uh just
for a second what have been the
individual problems at meta that are now
leading to so many people getting fired
well this is because
um method really I mean the the they
made a very uh humongously aggressive
bet on on the metaverse and you know
that hasn't really realized in the way
they thought it would
um and that's very important the other
thing that is happening to meta is that
you know in a way it's a Visionary it's
a missionary company so beyond the
metaverse they also try to compete with
the reserve currencies of the world if
you remember with Libra and it didn't
work either you know there's many many
attempts to disrupt that have worked
well and finally
um and because I cooperation I have to
say that there's also this disillusion
um for meta but I think it's more
General but but meta has suffered
probably the most is that they would
have open Skies you know what I mean
that the internet would be open to
everybody it is very clear by now and
this is China that this is not going to
be the case I have to say something
important Only Yesterday China it's
basically
reminded us of the importance of this
internet of mankind which basically
means separating you know creating an
Internet that is more protected so right
so that's not going to help meta
Alicia Garcia Herrero of the Texas
investment managers Alicia thank you
thank you